those who try to mimic martin luther
king's homiletic power and variably end
up looking sort of silly and that
actually happened to one of the first
who tried it when the young king was a
finalist for a church position for the
prestigious pulpit of dexter avenue
baptist church in Montgomery he
delivered a trial sermon called the
three dimensions of a complete life it
was a brilliant pitch with just the
right touches of erudition and oratory
and it reflected to an accomplished
culture to congregation exactly how they
understood themselves striving to
develop their best self service to
community and to God three dimensions of
a complete life well the other candidate
for that pulpit hearing the good reports
about his young King wanted to somehow
go one step further than King and
followed the next week with a sermon
entitled the four dimensions of a
complete life as you can imagine his
pitch fell completely flat it's best not
to come into a pulpit the Sunday after
Martin Luther King yet here we are after
king in our annual attempt to find words
that can recall Kings powerful voice or
tell us how to take a step further than
King doing so is always a hazardous
exercise not only because it can make
preachers look silly but because King
has become so many various things to our
memories that young pastor is now
remembered as a prophet called by the
Lord before he was born and given a
mouth like a sharpened sword one who led
a people out of bondage to the edge of a
promised land yet King has also become a
national hero of a country called the
United States so such statute that some
call him a second-generation founding
father his legacy has become one that
makes presidents stand up to use the
words of
before which are elected princes
prostrate themselves no matter how far
their own politics may diverge from
Kings he's also a cultural icon used to
construct various portraits of ourselves
so for a white preacher the hazards of
memory include and impulse to celebrate
king of the integrationist because that
lets euro-americans celebrate a man
ready to forgive white racism and see
the goodness of all Americans King that
nice man with a dream remembering king
that way can let us ignore the
landscapes of racism in which we still
live and perhaps most perilously king is
remembered as a saint his has become a
definitive Christian life there's a
statue of him in Westminster Abbey you
can buy religious icons of him he's
featured often in our prayer litanies
those are not necessarily bad forms of
memory I have one of those icons myself
on my office wall but remember Dorothy
days line about not wanting to be called
a saint because she did not want to be
so easily dismissed sainthood leads to
two kinds of dismissal in King's case
for his Christians like to commemorate
the Reverend Martin Luther King jr.
because we want to claim his work as the
churches but during his life king of
course was often snubbed by churches who
saw his mission as to socially involved
to dubiously political early on he had
hoped to work with Billy Graham but was
rebuffed he had hoped for support from
the National Baptist Convention his own
denomination but was subtly ignored he
became frustrated with Christians North
and South black and white liberal and
conservative who would listen to him in
church but not show up for the
theological drama happening in the
streets
he repeatedly wondered aloud about
churches that could tell the story of
God but could not see it happening
around them about Christians who worship
Jesus but refused to put themselves at
risk for others one of the most
devastating lines from his letter from a
Birmingham jail is directed at the
churches of the white moderate pastors
to whom he was writing I Drive past your
beautiful churches and I wonder what
kind of people worship there who is
their God King grew frustrated with
churches at the same time as he grew
closer to what he understood to be the
body of God for King discovered that the
God of justice and the Jesus of love was
real where people were putting their
bodies on a line for the sake of their
neighbors and their enemies these people
did not always identify themselves as
christian King saw that did not diminish
the spirit of Jesus Christ among them in
fact their actions showed up Kings faith
in the reality of the gospel so
Christians like to remember King as a
saint of the church what if he was a
saint he became one when he was not in
church second way that King suffers
dismissal by sainthood we tend to
remember King as one whose power and
vision was with him from the start one
who was called from before he was born
formed in the womb and given a mouth
like a sharpened sword so the strong
image can overwhelm those of us who may
aspire to justice but know ourselves
inadequate here's the memory of an
unequaled prophet bearing an
authoritative vision it can dampen the
expectations of we ordinary ones living
in ordinary times who do not see a
theological drama in our own streets we
would not presume to make righteousness
flow down like ass mighty stream
but King did not start out that way he
did not arrive in Montgomery looking
like a mighty prophet that first sermon
of King as a ministerial candidate the
three dimensions of a complete life is
surprising for how little it contains of
the Prophet we remember it's a little
stuffy surprisingly safe it's an
edifying humming no doubt there's no
foreshadow of a movement to end
segregation I'm not even really a
passing swipe at social injustice
there's no hint of a challenge to those
in the pews to risk themselves the sake
of others that is in fact a major reason
why the congregation a dexter avenue
liked it so much they were exhausted
with their previous pastor Vernon John's
who was as confrontational as he was
learning Dexter Avenue had hired John's
because he knew ancient languages could
reportedly recite the whole Bible for a
memory as well as volumes of ancient and
modern poetry it is in fact said of
John's that although he never needed the
Pew by of the pulpit Bible he worked
through three of them by counting on
them during church the congregation
became mortified of John's because he
refused his role of edifying the
cultural elite and instead bluntly
ridiculed segregation and publicly
shamed his own congregation for being
more concerned about social status than
social justice tired of John's making
trouble Dexter Avenue was looking for
safe and they hired Martin Luther King
jr. oops
what happened there safe thet well he
got caught up in the trouble of God
within a year King fell almost
accidentally into a role as the voice of
the Montgomery bus boycott there he
glimpsed what he would later call God
becoming real in history and perhaps the
greatest credit to his faith is that
once he caught that glimpse he gave
himself over to it once he glimpsed the
reality of Jesus moving by he knew what
he was looking for and he followed to
see where it would go and what it
required of him King learned his call
from that movement from that mission of
God at first he was not a pacifist but
when he was taught Gandhi and tactics
from the movement veterans he saw in
them the Spirit of Christ and made them
his own he still wasn't really sure how
non-violence could be redemptive until
he saw the students using their bodies
to reveal and absorb racist violence and
their actions he recognized the pattern
of the cross and developed his own
commitment to the redemptive power of
suffering he learned from Rabbi Abraham
Heschel and from the Buddhist monk
ticket on to connect the civil rights
struggle in the United States to the
struggle against injustice everywhere
from them he learned how his Christian
personalism must expand to a
cosmopolitan humanism he moved his
family and amongst the poor in Chicago
and from them he learned how civil
rights depends on employment and
fairness and housing from them he
learned that justice includes an
economics King is distinctive genius his
prophetic genius was to learn what his
lexicon of love and justice meant by
walking with those who seemed to have
something of the Spirit of Christ in
them the more he walked the more
maladjusted he became the first time
King let loose that trademark verse
justice roll down like waters and
righteousness like an ever-flowing
stream it was in support of a pretty
modest adjustment to bus segregation
laws by the end of his life when he came
to that verse and his sermon is
supported
vision that insisted on full integration
employment for all the poor decent
housing for every family the end of
American militarism and a turn away from
the materialism of the American dream
the waters of God's justice had carried
king further than he could have imagined
when he first uttered that voice during
the Montgomery bus boycott so when we
remember that verse we remember King
we're not only forced to confront how
stick our society still looks in light
of Kings final vision were invited to
enter those waters ourselves and be
changed by that is the womb in which
King the Prophet was formed King
preached that sermon the three
dimensions of a complete life over and
over in his career reading those
versions over time you can watch his
development as he turns that safe sermon
into an increasingly dangerous call to
get into the waters of justice or miss
out on the reality of God by the year of
his assassination but by which time he
was alienated from most churches that
sermon had turned from edifying too edgy
he still affirms that one dimension of a
complete life includes self-development
in fact underscores that you must
rightly love yourself but then he adds
the Good Samaritan parable to say that
Christians should not try to value their
security apart from others which means
not valuing yourself more than helping
your neighbors or by working for change
in your city by joining the movement
that is God becoming a real in history
he adds to the sermon a note of judgment
by invoking the saying of Jesus whatever
you have not done for the least for the
hungry and the imprisoned you have not
done for me Kings gloss on that versus
blunt on that day Jesus will say to
those were more concerned about their
careers than their neighbors get out of
my face but the year of his death for
saying things like that the one we
remember the Prophet a hero an icon a
saint had become unpopular
he saw that civil rights would be
meaningless if anyone's humanity was
disfigured by poverty so against the
advice of his strategists he joined the
Poor People's Campaign he saw that there
could be no possibility of non-violent
change in a nation trying to change
other countries by war so against the
advice of his remaining friends who came
out against Vietnam he saw that when
citizens are too involved in their own
ambitions and their things they don't
get involved the movements to confront
racism or to help how's the poor and
they support wars undertaken to protect
their resources so he denounced middle
class materialism as an obstacle to
justice King became more maladjusted the
deeper he let his life be transformed by
God's mission of love for neighbors and
enemies in fact in the last version of
the three dimensions of a complete life
King tells us that that is how he hopes
to be remembered in my eulogy says King
anticipating a nearing end I would like
it to be said that i tried to love
others an explanation of this
maladjustment this complex social vision
he says remember me as one who tried to
witness to God by doing something for
others Cornel West says of this that by
the end of his life King had learned
that the meaning of human life reduces
to this question to what will your death
bear witness and King wanted to bear
witness to the attempt to love others
may be the most hopeful thing about
King's legacy is that he learned how to
do it to some extent he learned how to
bear that witness just by getting
involved by showing up and letting the
waters of justice carry him along you
don't need to first have a divine
mandate to do justice you don't need the
sharpen the sword of a complete social
theory to try to love your neighbor King
love to say that
don't need a PhD to figure this out you
don't need a powerful position just go
to where people are trying to love
others especially where they're trying
to love enemies especially when they're
doing it for the sake of the poor of the
desperate or the homeless or they
imprison in our gospel today Jesus see
some people following after him and he
asked them what are you looking for and
they reply where are you staying and he
says come and see come and see come and
find the justice you seek but don't
fully understand come and learn the love
that is your humanity learn to love
those called enemies learn to seek
justice with the poor of this city you
can start today you can take a step with
the homeless who in this city struggle
to find beds even in the midst of this
cold winter do that and you'll glimpse
the spirit of Jesus and you will find
your own humanity that's how king said
he wanted to be remembered show up where
the reality of God in history is
happening and you'll start to see that
theological drama in your own Street and
you'll be on your way to the several
dimensions of a maladjusted life